vamos a aprovechar estos minutos para
seguir trabajando con este interesante
problema de motores emisiones partes por
millón y demás cuestiones sin embargo en
este caso vamos a cambiar la pregunta
vamos a buscar ahora un intervalo de
confianza de un 95 por ciento
entonces tenemos los datos de estos 10
motores que fueron analizados
y con la ayuda de ellos podemos calcular
muy fácilmente la media de la muestra
que es 17 17 podemos calcular también
ese que es la desviación típica de esta
muestra que es 298 entonces lo que
necesitamos buscar ahora es trabajar
vamos a hacer
la distribución normalizada una
distribución normalizada y porque te
porque tenemos 10 motores solo una
muestra muy pequeña entonces realizamos
la curva
y vamos a tener
el mundo
y vamos a tener que buscar qué es lo que
nos pide en qué intervalo
vamos a suponer que en este intervalo
tenemos un 95%
entonces que tenemos que averiguar qué
intervalo tiene ese 95 es decir cuáles
son estos valores entonces si tenemos un
95% y buscamos un 5% en la tabla de
valores z en la tabla de valores este
perdón vamos a estar entonces si me
permiten buscarlo en el valor que
necesitamos acá estamos nuevamente con
la tabla t de dos colas entonces 5% es
0.05
y como tenemos la muestra de 10 tenemos
9 grados de libertad
entonces buscamos hasta que se
encuentren y llegamos a 2 2,262 s
entonces va a ser uno de los extremos de
nuestro intervalo
tenemos acá 22 62 y en este caso
entonces vamos a tener el negativo -2 26
es decir que nuestro valor
nuestro valor t
va a estar o tiene un 95 por ciento de
estar
entre 22 62 y menos 22 62 pero nosotros
también sabemos y esto nos va a servir
lo que queremos averiguar es que te es
igual a 17 17 que es el valor de x barra
- 1
sobre 298 sobre la raíz de 10 que esta
cuestión de acá es lo que nos daba s
sobre la raíz de la cantidad de muestras
entonces podemos expresar esta es esta
cuestión de la siguiente manera
- 22 62 es menor que
1717 menos
sobre
09 42 que 09 42 es esta cuestión de acá
pero con otro color estar acá es igual a
09 42
a su vez toda esta expresión es menor a
2,22 entonces tenemos una ecuación o una
in ecuación simple con dos extremos de
la que tenemos que conseguir
el valor de mí
entonces multiplicamos ambos miembros
ambos miembros en verdad multiplicamos
los tres miembros por 09 42
por 09 42 y también acá por 09 42 estos
se van a simplificar y las vaqueras
menos 22 62 por 09 42 menor a 17 17
menos
menor 22 62 x 09 42
resolvemos nuevamente todas estas
multiplicaciones y obtenemos que esto es
menos 2 13 menor a 17,17 menos hoy vamos
a expresar a muy con otro color para
identificarlo menor
2 13
cabe destacar que este 2 13 menos 2,3
surge de aquí y este 2,3 surgen aquí de
verdad entonces ahora vamos a reescribir
esto de otra forma vamos a multiplicar a
todos x menos 1 como para modificar esta
cuestión que nos está molestando con el
menos mucho entonces si multiplicamos a
todos x menos uno nos va a cambiar el
sentido de los símbolos y vamos a tener
mayor
- 17 17 mayor a menos 213
sumamos 17 17 en todos los miembros 213
más 17 17 es mayor que me vamos a
escribir a mí otra vez insisto con otro
color
mayor al menos 213
más 1717 entonces ya estamos llegando a
una buena a un buen símbolo
esto es entonces 19 3 mayor que m
mayor que 15,04 entonces fíjense lo que
llegamos con un sencillo problema
valiéndonos de la tabla de valor este y
conociendo que tenemos o que necesitamos
un intervalo del 95% llegamos a
encontrar que tenemos un 95% de
probabilidades
de que me
de que la media universal de los motores
que estamos realizando se encuentre en
entre 15 04 partes por millón y 19 3 es
decir que hay muchas probabilidades
justamente 95% de que cumplamos con la
nueva norma que se nos exige es que
estar en menos de 20 partes por millón
entonces si tenemos que pagar vamos a
escribir la otra forma
15 04
menor a un menor a 19 3 que no está
entre estos valores entre 15 04 y 19 con
más tres en un 95%